heißen sie mich für naiv also ich habe
jetzt nicht jeden wir haben in unserem
Manifest nicht jeden Schritt
ausgearbeitet das muss natürlich Hand in
Hand gehen und erst dann
wenn die Russen anfangen sich aus den am
24 Februar vergangenen Jahres besetzen
Gebieten zurückzuziehen erst dann kann
man sagen und es ist ein wirklich echten
Waffenstillstand gibt erst dann sagt man
man liefert keine Waffen mehr ist ja
klar aber nur dieses Waffen liefern ohne
jeden diplomatischen Versuch das heißt
einmal richtig verstehen sie sagen jetzt
Voraussetzung für den Stoff von
Waffenlieferung muss schon sein dass die
sich zurückziehen habe ich wieder
richtig verstehen
will stillstand gibt ja und da und im
Anschluss an den wirklich
eingelösten ernsthaften Waffenstillstand
gibt es die Verhandlungen und dann
müssen beide Seiten Kompromisse machen
ich habe ein bisschen anders verstanden
auch hier im man Test Frau Schwarzer das
heißt damit sagen sie solange Waffen
liefern ist okay solange die
russennische Armee sich keinen
Zentimeter bewegt und weiter nach vorne
beginnen die russische Armee also
selensky hat im vergangenen Herbst ein
Dekret erlassen die Kredit hier kommt
der Befehl des Präsidenten das nicht
verhandelt werden darf also das heißt
wir spielen gegen will wir kämpfen gegen
diese größte Atom Macht der Welt zu lang
bis hier kein Mann und keine Maus mehr
ist und das ganze Land zerstört ist wir
sehen in diesen Tagen den russischen
Machthaber Vladimir Putin bei
Feierlichkeiten in Moskau und sehen ihn
unter anderem so sprechen
auch im Moskauer Stadion vor 10.000
jubelnden Menschen vor Soldaten vor
Kindern noch einmal das für die
Eskalation ausschließlich der Westen
verantwortlich sei was empfinden Sie bei
diesen Auftritten einmal den Kopf
ausschalten was empfinden Sie bei denen
sagen ich sehe ein Beweis dafür dass
beim Krieg immer die einen sagen wir
sind die guten und die anderen sind die
Bösen und die anderen sagen wir sind
aber die guten die anderen es gibt aber
was soll an ihm gut sein also wenn Sie
wenn Sie sagen hier ist nicht gut und
böse klar verteilt seine Auffassung
seine Auffassung
und ich würde auch sagen
es geht hier nicht um Moral es geht hier
nicht darum wie man Herr putet oder eine
selensky oder an beiden findet ja es
geht um Machtverhältnisse und es geht
darum Menschen irgendwann wird immer
gesagt unschuldige Menschen aber ich
finde entschuldige davon auch nicht
einfach umbringen also Menschen zu
schützen dass man sie in den Krieg wirft
ins Wasser wird dann aber schauen Sie
ich wollte einmal rausfinden weil wir
alle haben Gefühl auch zu diesen Bildern
das macht was mit uns wenn es diese
Auftritte gibt dort äh vor seinen
Militärs dann später auch im
Fußballstadion mir läuft er ehrlich
gesagt ein kalter Schauder über den
Rücken was empfinden Sie dabei
ich nehme das ernst und ich finde das
sehr bedrohlich und ich meine dass wir
uns mit der größten Atommacht der Welt
an einen Tisch setzen sollten und reden
und ich weiterballern weil irgendwann
kommt dann die finale Waffe und sie
wissen was das ist und da sitzen wir
auch hier in Deutschland und in Europa
nicht mehr im Trocknen wenn Sie mit dem
verhandeln müssten dann sitzen sie an
einem sehr langen Tisch wie wir wissen
an den kleinen Sätze also ich muss in
der Zeit mit dem Chinesen und dann sagt
er ihnen verantwortlich für die
Eskalation sind alleine sie ist alleine
der Westen
sie aber das haben die anderen auch ich
würde ihm antworten wissen sie lassen ja
mal die Vorgeschichte die kompliziert
ist seit 9 Jahren gibt es ja da ein Hin
und Her in der Ukraine wo im Grunde die
beiden Weltmächte zusammenprallen ich
würde sagen das interessiert uns jetzt
nicht lieber herr Präsident wir wollen
dass das Sterben aufhört und jetzt sagen
Sie mal ihrem Preis und dann nicht
meinen Preis und sie wissen ja das ist
auch auf dem Markt so auf dem arabischen
Markt doch ein bisschen stärker als bei
uns dann fängt man an zu verhandeln zu
gucken wo kann ich Konzessionen machen
mein einziges Bestreben ist für die
Menschen dass dieser Krieg so bald wie
möglich aufhört wir führen ihn wir alle
weil wir wissen führt ja durch seine
Waffenlieferung diesen Krieg mit wir
führen ihn seit einem Jahr
das positive Resultat ist dass die
Ukraine sich dank der Unterstützung des
Westens zur Wehr setzen konnte nicht
also das war ja ein brutaler Überfall
auf das Land und deswegen finde ich es
richtig dass wir zunächst Waffen
geliefert haben das ist das Positive ja
und der Adresse hat gesehen so einfach
ist das nicht ist kein Spaziergang wegen
der Krim und die Stimmung anders ist
sondern die sagen moment mal ja draußen
bleiben
das Negative ist dass es sich zieht und
zieht und zieht und immer mehr verhärtet
wer immer mehr in diesem Hass denken
drin sind ja also hier sind die Menschen
und da sind die Monster und so weiter
und wenn man aber uns ein bisschen
verrückten und gehen in dem Perspektive
dann sehen wir dass die das genau
umgekehrt sehen lassen sie uns lassen
Sie einfach schauen wie wir aus diesem
Krieg rauskommen und wie wir und hoffen
dass wir uns nicht immer mehr einem
atomkrecht nähern
es geht hier um die Existenz der Welt
also der UN-Generalsekretär guteras der
hat ja jüngst gesagt wir gehen nicht
schlafen dadurch in diesen Krieg ist
eine Anspielung auf auf einen wuchttitel
sondern wir gehen mit offenen Augen in
den weltkriegt das sagt der
UN-Generalsekretär ich bitte Sie was
soll man denn noch sagen